sobre el tema de francia márquez ella en
este momento creo que es la gran
ganadora realmente de todo este
escenario lo de petro era obvio pero lo
de francia plantea un escenario que es
el efecto de los de los perdedores de
las consultas cuando se hace un
ejercicio no necesariamente para ganar
en este escenario presidencial sino tal
vez como una catapulta a un trampolín
hacia otros espacios en 2014 uno de los
candidatos que hace parte de esta misma
consulta que se llama camilo romero en
el país él participó en una consulta
dentro de la cual sacó 700.000 votos y
luego de eso pues pudo llegar a la
gobernación de su departamento en nariño
lo mismo sucedió en 2018 con carlos
caicedo que compitió en esa oportunidad
con gustavo petro sacó más de 500.000
votos y actualmente es el gobernador del
departamento del magdalena seguramente
lo que yo le auguro a francia- márquez
es que si ella llegase a hacer hoy la
fórmula vicepresidencial de gustavo
petro y fueran en segunda vuelta y
perdieran incluso en el peor escenario
que sería representante a la cámara en
este momento en el país por una figura
que es el estatuto de la oposición
incluso si ella decidiera dar un paso al
costado tendría la posibilidad de
estrenar en departamentos en colombia
como valle del cauca o incluso el
departamento del cauca a los clanes
políticos tradicionales creo que es la
tiene la fuerza suficiente para
perfilarse con un cuadro político
interesante dentro del pacto histórico o
por fuera de él